you were working ColdFusion TV hi
welcome to another ColdFusion video this
video is going to be something a little
bit different it's pretty exciting and
frankly amazing
[Music]
for the longest time it was thought that
brain damage such as that caused by a
stroke is permanent and irreversible but
a recent medical breakthrough is
bringing this notion into question
researchers at Stanford University have
been blown away by the results of a
clinical trial they conducted among
other amazing stories a wheelchair-bound
stroke victim has regained the ability
to walk after stem cells were injected
directly into the brain it's all pretty
crazy but in this video we'll take a
look as defined by the u.s. national
institution of health a stroke is a
medical condition in which poor blood
flow to the brain results in cell death
Stanford University tested a new method
for a covering damaged brain tissue the
surgical procedure involved 18 stroke
patients that were at the plateau stage
of recovery at this stage there's
typically no more potential for recovery
in motor coordination that's pretty much
it
that's the best it's gonna get they
usually taken out of therapy because
it's believed that their brains have
been damaged in key areas beyond repair
during the trial
surgeons drilled a hole into the skull
of the patients and injected human adult
stem cells around the damaged areas of
the brain amazingly these stem cells
then triggered the damaged areas of the
brain to repair themselves within days
patients could move limbs again and
begin to speak properly when they
couldn't previously they could even be
sent home on the same day as the surgery
here's a news report from CBS on the
topic it is amazing we have some
remarkable video to show you tonight
stroke victims making incredible
progress literally overnight thanks to a
new kind of treatment at Stanford five
years ago Sonya Kuhn suffered a stroke
that severely damaged her brain this is
Sonya stroke it partially paralyzed
Sonya on her right side and she could
barely speak her speech was not very
understandable she couldn't order food
or communicate well two years later
Sonya could still hardly lift her arm
but just one day after an experimental
treatment
Sonia could lift her arm over her head
to the side and move it to the side and
also to the front and her words began to
flow I woke up and immediately I could
speak inventor dr. Gary Steinberg chair
of neurosurgery at Stanford led the
small clinical trial eighteen chronic
stroke patients were involved twelve
came to Stanford including Sonya I think
I think I cried in a trial Steinberg
drilled a tiny hole into the patient's
skull and using a very fine needle
injected modified human adult stem cells
around the stroke you put them around
the stroke and that's where they do
their thing to recover the function
these cells don't survive for long after
the surgery but they appear to trigger a
patient's damaged brain to begin to heal
itself the cells somehow jumpstart the
system again here's another stroke
patient just before surgery
here she is just days after receiving
the stem-cell treatment as for Sonya her
life is back on track she's now married
and pregnant her first child and there's
a boy yeah according to Gary Steinberg
chairperson of neurosurgery at Stanford
one of the patients was a 71 year old
wheelchair-bound individual who could
walk again after the stem-cell surgery
this event has shocked everyone on the
research team quote their recovery was
not just minimal recovery like someone
who couldn't move a thumb and now being
able to wiggle it it was much more
meaningful one 71 year-old
wheelchair-bound patient was walking
again he goes on this could
revolutionize our concept of what
happens not only in stroke but traumatic
brain injury and every neurodegenerative
disorder we thought the brain circuits
were dead and we've learned that they're
not unquote say Gary seems to hint that
stem cells could be used to treat other
neurodegenerative diseases like
Parkinson's or Alzheimer's alright so
that's all well and good but let's dig a
little deeper what exactly asked
themselves
stem cells are a very remarkable type of
cell they have the ability to change
themselves into any other type of cell
during early life and growth in tissues
they serve as a sort of internal repair
system dividing essentially without
limit to replenish other cells as long
as the person is alive they can even do
this after long periods of inactivity
when a stem cell divides each new cell
has the potential to either remain a
stem cell or become another type of cell
with a more specialized function such as
a muscle cell a red blood cell or in
this case a brain cell in some organs
such as the gut and bone marrow stem
cells regularly divide to repair and
replace worn-out damaged tissues in
other organs however such as the
pancreas and heart stem cells only
divide under special conditions the
cells used in the Stanford surgery were
SB 623 stem cells these cells are
actually a product a standby
incorporated SB 623 a bone marrow
derived stem cells from adult donors the
new idea here is that these special stem
cells have been genetically engineered
to repair damaged cells when introduced
according to the World Health
Organization 15 million people suffer
strokes worldwide each year of these
five million died and another five
million are permanently disabled once
knowing this it becomes easy to see the
huge potential of this medical
breakthrough
right now the Stanford team is now
moving into Phase two of the trial with
a hundred and fifty three patients on
the list they're going to see if these
results can be replicated I'm definitely
wishing Gary and his team all the best I
personally think that this is really
awesome to see these are the very early
days of stem-cell genetic research and
the technology can only get better from
here clearly a huge potential lives
within stem cells genetic engineering it
definitely can be used for good and it's
nice to see this technology being used
in that way as a side point a lot of
this just shows how little we know about
the human brain and in a way we tend to
take it for granted every day so what do
you guys think let me know your thoughts
in the comment section below anyway I
thought I'll just bring that story to
you guys so thanks for watching if you
need to this channel feel free to
subscribe this has been - go go you're
been watching cold fusion and I'll see
you again soon for the next video cheers
guys have a good one
cold fusion it can you thinking
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you